[Musique]
émilie nicolas michel sauget christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir
alors on peut pas voulu faire entendre
faire entendre cette blague de monsieur
legault dit il mauvaise blague il
reconnaît monsieur volume 1,1 milliard
cas parce qu'elle n'est pas audible elle
était hors micro mais tout le monde l'a
rendu
il monsieur arrive nous donne le
contexte mon cher quand on se lève je
pense que des images pour poser une
question et là monsieur legault leur
garde mes dires ils s'aiment il n'y a
pas eu pendant lui était pas mon lui et
ça créé une vive réaction du côté de la
banque et minéraux on va écouter des
réactions de monsieur arcand d'abord le
premier intéressé et de monsieur legault
ans et
ça sert à quoi tout ce qu'on a fait si
on est traité comme ça
de la façon dont il va traiter
alors je voulais juste vous dire
simplement que je suis ébranlé très
fortement et aujourd'hui je peux
simplement vous dire qu'il n'était pas
digne d'être premier ministre même si
j'accepte les excuses ça demeure pas
moins que je pense que les québécois
doivent prendre note un moment donné qui
a une limite à l'arrogance je comprends
qu'il ya une joute parlementaire qui
doit se faire mais à un moment donné
pour employer une expression c'est un
coup en bas de la ceinture
car qu'un film on se connaît on se voit
chez lui chez moi je les apprécie
beaucoup et puis je trouve que dominique
anglade l'utilisent pas assez que
qu'elle lui donne pas assez de questions
à poser puis c'est assez spécial parce
que ce matin quand j'ai vu qu'ils se
lever enfin le sud-liban enfin il est
pas mort on l'utilisent enfin donc c'est
positif à l'égard de pierre - les gars
d'être de dominique mais c'est une
mauvaise place était mal perçue puis je
me suis tout excuser
et d'ailleurs c'est par tweet que
monsieur legault dès qu'il a prononcé
tout cela dit pierre arcand est une amie
c'est une mauvaise blague je me suis
excusé ben alors émilie nicolas je
commence avec vous comme bas comment vos
richesses que mauvaise blague isolé ou
sa note espèce d'arrogance envers
l'opposition
[Musique]
donc on parle tout d'un trait de
caractère si on pollue d'autres
démonstrations
je pense pas qu'on serait en train de
même se poser la question s'il n'y avait
pas eu d'autres choses dans la façon
dont le premier ministre se comporte à
l'assemblée à travailler ailleurs qu'il
en soit que la question la question se
pose enfin on peut penser aussi à yves
françois blanchet durant la campagne
électorale c'est aussi une question qui
était posée mais d'accumulation
d'anecdotes de choses qui parle c'est
toi qui fais en sorte qu on le sait n'a
utilisé ce mot là c'est ce que le
premier ministre qu'on semblait pouvoir
à la famille nationale depuis longtemps
avec avec la mesure sur les étals et
peugeot jean sanitaire s'aperçoit que
beaucoup beaucoup de concertation
pouvoir l'assemblée nationale
ça donne un gouvernement qu'une très
forte majorité il peut s'asseoir sur ses
lauriers et c'est pas la première fois
que des commentaires des plastiques sont
arrivées ce mot leur arrogance à se
poser la question de sa cause de tout ce
contexte ces parcours de ce qui s'est
passé ce matin mais chez c'est
effectivement je dire depuis un bout de
temps on peut pas critiquer gouvernement
même quand on parle de choses comme le
troisième et qui est très contestable
leurs noms n'ont tous ceux qui veulent
passer parce que et alors ça devient un
peu une halte de kaunas bon c'était
peut-être une mauvaise blague sur
monsieur arquin qui est cinéma mérite
pas ça veut dire c'est quelqu'un qui qui
qualité chef intérimaire de son parti
c'est peut-être pire job d'assistant
parlementaire et chef intérimaire mais
monsieur leveaux en essayant de
s'excuser c'est qu'elle est encore plus
vous haussez mon ami je veux payer chez
eux des fois tout ça aux dix poids des
affaires de même quand on parle d'un
ennemi enfin pendant les gens que je
fréquente qu'est-ce que ça réveille
question du four vous pensez à un manque
de sensibilité de la part du premier
ministre à l'égard de monsieur arcand
qui a été très mal traités par la
société québécoise lors de la pandémie
moi j'étais un de ceux qui le défendent
y souvenez vous lors de l'odieux épisode
des touristes atta ali vers le 2020 2021
le camp tout le québec voulait avoir des
boucs émissaires on a choisi monsieur
harker parce qu'elle veut une malheur
d'aller dans le sud puis lors on se met
à taper sur lui ça ne pouvait qu'être
très blessants pour monsieur arcand il
rappelé au cnam anglade l'avait pas
défendu à ce moment là
parallèlement question elle vient même à
alger ses responsabilités ça donc c'est
dans ce contexte là on sent que monsieur
arcand ça a réveillé cette blessure le
ça ne pouvait pas faire autrement dit ce
qui ma rue donc grand manque de
sensibilité de monsieur legault je pense
qu'on doit attribuer sont au fait que le
gouvernement du québec mois dans une
ennemie
gouverner sans opposition comme une
espèce de docilité incroyable de tous
les faiseurs d'opinion dans la dynamique
de la victoire en terre au fond donc
l'info que le gouvernement accepte que
de l'opposition pour respecter merci 13
ses traits insensible franchement
d'avoir ce monsieur arcand et est-ce que
ça va être ce qui apporte ici et là un
manque de respect justement envers
l'opposition envers le rôle de
l'opposition
sur des fraudes dites oui ils sont des
habitués de pollution pas d'un ennemi en
avait pas de position y'avait vie grand
mix quotidien de tous les québécois
disaient oui oui oui oui oui ils sont
habitués à ça il faut qu'ils se
déshabitue et le personnel politique sur
twitter c'est un phénomène relativement
nouveau québec personnel politique qui
attaquent certains élus de l'opposition
ou qui rit de etc il ya quand même bien
glissement michel c'est ce que vous le
notez aussi un test d'agressivité en
fait qu'on voyait moins peut-être qu'on
la voyant privé mais moins sur les
réseaux
écoutez le soir de l'élection partielle
de marie victorin
maintenant les positions
partisanes il y avait kamel 65% du monde
qu'elle a voté contre quand le parti au
pouvoir cette journée le nom alors le
moment
c'est toujours la faute des autres c'est
nous on a le cas pour continue bon pas
besoin de charger jamais ça s'est un peu
c'est un peu frustrant mais c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'ils voient
qu'ils vont induire à la cagoule noire
de l'élection vous savez un moment donné
quand les gens disent le gouvernement va
être trop fort je pense qu'on va leur
envoyer une forte opposition quant à
monsieur vous dit oui l'ont fait d'avoir
100 sièges ça me dérange pas ok ce que
rêve vous allez gagner transformer le
mode de scrutin vous n'êtes pas mal qui
est sidérant de problèmes comme neige je
souhaitais je pense que je peux repartir
mais mais justement emilie c'est une
époque quand on est très fort
très puissant qu'on doit être encore
plus respectueux envers des oppositions
qui en arrachent parti libéral le secret
pour personne cependant très bonne
période est ce qu'on a besoin d'insister
à ce point et me mêle c'est sûr que dans
l'opinion publique pour le dire en
termes très clairs précis sur du monde à
terre
ça donne une belle image ceci dit il ya
aussi quelque chose d'intéressant par ce
qui se passe sur twitter parce que en
fait les conseillers politiques surtout
aux libéraux tenaient dans d'autres
camions aussi qu'ils se servent de la
plateforme pour dire des choses tout au
qui pourrait pas dire au nom et au nom
des élus donc la ligne est complètement
flou entre 6,1 stéphane gobeil par
exemple quand il police s'exprime au nom
de police où s'exprime en son nom
personnel kan qui est truqué mesa et
qu'il sait des gens de pollution et on
joue sur ce coup là tout est art est la
combine ici et beaucoup dé gens d'un
grand public sont pas le savoir assidu
là dessus je ne sais pas exactement
c'est quoi le but des conseillers qu'en
ile de france à j'ai jamais vu de
journal et se reprendre les speed qui
ont été mis de l'avant comme ça mais ça
c'est juste mais en fait puni un camp
séquences et a atteint un niveau de la
dette qui dépasse la l'annoncé repris
dans le style de nouvelles et ça fait
jamais bien paraître je comprends
très bien projet de loi 96 un projet de
loi important c'est la pièce qui sera
qui sera qui deviendra loi ce printemps
importante je préparais pour nous
remettre dans le bain deux trois
tableaux les grandes lignes ne s'est pas
tout les c'est pas toutes les
dispositions de la loi cadre du projet
de loi 96 le cégep pendant 1 beaucoup
parlé limiter la croissance des places
donc réserver la croissance des places
aux ayants droit donc à ceux qui ont le
droit d'aller où que ce qu'ils ont fait
tout leur tous leurs cours en anglais
suivre ça c'est le finalement c'est la
mode m'a eu ça ressemble à l'amendement
des libéraux que les libéraux avaient
voulu enlever remettre le soc une autre
histoire là la valse hésitation des
libéraux là dessus mais suivent trois
cours de français supplémentaires dans
les quatre sessions pour pour les élèves
pour les ayants droit donc qu'il part
mieux français
je vous la langue du travail prochain
tableau je vous résume un rapidement
touche à la langue du travail assujettir
les entreprises à la charte les plus
petites entreprises et encadrer les
exigences d'autres langues
l'exemple c'est quand monsieur jolie
barrette a voulu
dire à la cour vous ne vous n'avez pas
le droit d'exiger le bilinguisme alors
on veut réduire les exigences du
bilinguisme puis finalement inscrire le
québec français dans la concession
canadienne très clairement sur vous
aviez appelé dit christian l'époque je
me suis ou doute oublié que c'est très
très bon bon il ya d'autres il ya
d'autres éléments mais c'est les gros
éléments
tour de table je pense qu'avec vous
christian cette fois ci il ya peu de lui
des débats les libéraux ça peut être
très claire lamarche bagdad deux ont
voté contre aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est une avancée importante
quand ce projet de loi va devenir une
loi d'après vous pour le français au
québec oui mais ça me suit une avancée
je pense chapeau à simon jeu les
barrettes pour le compromis en fait
qu'il a annoncé aujourd'hui en ce qui a
trait aux cours d'anglais en fait pour
o2 france et pardon au cégep les
libéraux l'ont appuyé je trouve que
c'est respectueux de la minorité
historique anglophone faut jamais
oublier que les anglo québécois de
souche qu'on appelle les ayants droit ce
sont des québécois depuis toujours et
puis que l'anglais est une langue
québécoise à promettre sur le même temps
que le français qui doit clairement
prédominant donc je trouve le compromis
sur le marais tu vas dans ce sens nos
ses seins pour si ça répond à une
préoccupation de plus en plus importante
c'est que les jeunes anglo québécois par
moins français que leurs aînés ça ça
commençait documenté c'est inquiétant
donc ça c'est intéressant comme vous
l'avez appris avec une très bonne
mémoire moi je suis très sensible à ce
qu'ils vont faire ce qu'est ce qu'ils
vont essayer d'insérer dans la
constitution canadienne j'espère qu'ils
vont parler de la société distingue en
majorité francophone passe très
important soit dans le dossier de
l'intégration des immigrants du refus du
multiculturalisme canadien sans limite
qui est en train de détruire quelque
chose au québec et aussi le dossier du
cégep en français ce qu'on impose la loi
101 au cégep c'est facile à quel point
il ya un mouvement très très fort au
sein de l'opinion publique qui voudrait
que le gouvernement aille jusque là le
prémice le groupe a c'est lui qui bloque
manifestement sentent pas vouloir le
faire parce que je pense qu'il veut pas
se faire accuser d'être radical et enfin
ça mais le parti libéral devant un
dilemme bon je pense pas qu'ils vont
voter en faveur de la loi par citron un
symbole en fait pour leur clientèle
anglo québécoise mais leur refus va être
un parti officiel parce que le point qui
accrochait c'était vraiment les cours de
9,2 français qu'on imposait aux anglo
québécois mais votre choix globalement
on va voir le toit ça va être terminé
mais selon jobim en jeu les bars et son
avocat m naviguer intérêts de façon
intéressante là dedans michel résumé
fait une synthèse aussi de ce que ça va
d'après vous changer quels sont les
éléments tête est plus important selon
vous
je pense que ça changerait pas grand
chose parce que on est dans la situation
un peu étrange où les gens disent oh la
loi ça ne marche pas faisons plus de
lois sont tous contre tous le projet de
loi c'est de serrer un peu de hauteur de
tours les boulons qui était dans la loi
ça mais si à la fin du sud du cégep il
ya plein de gens qui sortent du sujet
qui parle pas français ils ont suivi la
loi ça râle dont il faut bien y vont pas
vrai s'inscriront des couronnes 3 courts
de plus obligatoire de français silva si
on prenait le thé capable d'apprendre le
français au primaire et au secondaire
obligatoire au cégep pour preuve à
charge est là peut-être que la façon
dont on a cet air france et pour là
aussi beaucoup de jeunes anglophones se
plaignent de ce moment on fait de la
conjugaison des verbes qui on n'apprend
pas comment comment parler cette langue
mais
l'autre chose là bas c'est le gros lot
de la cac très peu d'entre eux ne sais
pas quels sont les symboles tels sont
des choses qu'il faut pour toucher 1
dirait mois donné on va arrêter
je vous dis ça comme ça
ça sa irai de beaucoup de gens et mais
du pq avait déjà comme des bêtes et puis
d'autres
il y avait des hommes
il y avait des inscrits dans la
communauté la france avait il y avait un
baromètre la quête mano pot de sauce et
c'est pour ça que ça fait peur de boire
dans communauté anglophone si on avait
passé plus de temps à expliquer peuvent
bénéficier certaines choses on a
peut-être eu moins de problèmes oui
démystifier certaines choses comme vous
dites parce que il ya les faits puis
aussi une interprétation qui a été donné
il faut avoir des canaux ouverts pour
discuter entre eux et lui noté emilie
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'ensemble
de l'oeuvre
c'est en fait je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont résisté au projet de loi
96 qu'ils font qu'ils font pour pour les
inquiétudes qui sont liées à la le
projet va punir des gens qui sont
finalement le produit du système tu peux
m'expliquer par exemple les études
anglophones qui ont pollué le cas
raisons d'apprendre le français encore
parce que les cours de 30e ce cadre le
fort de son passé fort s'ils ont créé il
y avait cette mesure de qui avait été
gardée en place parce qu'on m'a empêché
de prendre le titre collégiale si le
niveau de francs cfa c'est bon ce qu'on
fait en fait c'est punir des individus
alors que c'est le système marqué par
français dès le primaire puisque gonnard
un autre chose aussi qui a suscité
beaucoup d'inquiétude c'est la question
des services black's de l'accès aux
services dans une autre langue que le
français du service public
je me suis par exemple il ya beaucoup
personnes autochtones qui se sont
inquiétés de ça parce que dans les faits
même si il ya des gens doivent pouvoir
s'ils le peuvent offrir des services en
anglais par exemple dans les services
essentiels
beaucoup de gens qui ont pas la même
qualité de service lorsque davantage en
anglais les gens se tombe dit est ce que
fait loi ne vaut faire en sorte que les
gens vont être encore moins bien servi
quand il reprend le français contre la
langue maternelle c'est son aura que
c'est son fils et son unique puis ces
choses ne sont pas dans la loi mais
l'inquiétude est quand même là puis
juste avant puisque la cac et des
connectiques ces communautés leur sont
les rassure pas mais ça crée des
mouvements essentiellement de panique
qui on cherche pas on prend pas c'est
plus facile au sérieux on va pas
chercher non plus à répondre à la crise
qui passeront de base c'est-à-dire
lorsque les gens à être servi à
l'hôpital dans une autre langue et on
peut lui même sous une tente et elle
amène de la même qualité pour la santé
oui parce que même si objectivement les
éléments encore une fois du projet de
loi
quand on quand on les regarde
indépendamment
ils ne sont ils ne suffisent pas à
monter une grande anxiété chez beaucoup
d'anglophones ou de
celle ci il faut aller l'expliqué là
c'est ça qui a manqué pas te soutient
oui michel raison a fait de souligner
que ce qui manque aujourd'hui ce qui
existait avant c'était plus de ponts en
fait entre la communauté anglophone puis
la majorité francophone et le
gouvernement avant il y avait des lives
alliance québec avec comme organisation
qui avait beaucoup de crédibilité des
gens comme louise cohen comme greta
chambers comme kevin rudd même john
parizel on ne put tellement de ce2 de
ces gens là et ce qui fait qu'elle soit
mariée peut avoir beaucoup de
malentendus et de la danse y était pour
rien moi je persiste à penser que c'est
une grosse erreur que le monsieur
legault n'appliquent pas la loi 101 au
cégep parce que cette fois là va quand
même manqué d'un moteur d'une énergie
d'une espèce de choc puis élément
inquiétant c'est que pino madame anglade
le quand même aujourd'hui le qualifie d'
extrémistes c'est à dire loin quand même
mais de nouveau partie anglophone qui
vont être créés et je comprends que
c'est pas dans son intérêt mais c'est
vrai que c'est parti le prêche pour le
bilinguisme au québec alors qu'avant
soir était invraisemblable que des
organismes sérieux anglophones québécois
prêche pour le bilinguisme avastin est
clair que celle français qui devait être
clairement prix de milan donc il ya
quand même un manque l'application de la
loi 101 aux cégeps ares si monsieur le
golf est pas je pense qu'il va le
regretter mais voilà que j'étais
longtemps bon il fera pas celle ces
mélanges passé c'était très clair soit
finie tant que c'est pas fini mon char
revoir brisé sur la réforme
ils le feront pas
c'est jacques lassalle voit deux raisons
que
ça change rien au fait que les
universités anglophones juste le symbole
serait omnipuissant voilà débat qui se
pose on va à la pause merci beaucoup
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit